hey guys I'm Ryan Wright and I'm Mark
Ellis aka the perfect guy the perfect
guy is right here next to me
schmooze know what don't you know oh man
I'm so excited to be here - I've never
done a trailer reaction live on camera
this would be my very first one really a
little nervous oh my god B it's the
hardest job in this world so you look
very professional right now oh thank you
thank you my cue lights and camera
anyway guys we're gonna check out the
trailer for the perfect guy oh wait now
I've seen the first trailer that's right
he's not the perfect guy he said based
on the story of my life we'll have to
find out I know very little about this
movie and I've never seen the trailer so
I'm pumped here we go they did the
grease racing scene this wasn't it very
sad they made
the one I hope something got anger
issues
Lloris justice ladies investment like
that to town for one day I'd be happy
oh that scene in Naked Gun two and a
half
oh-hoo DeNiro in Cape Fear under the bed
I just saw that were like today's gonna
be fantastic
prime solar and this interesting
interesting what do you think man like I
I actually like the first trailer a
little more because this woman seemed
like he was trying to do Fifty Shades of
Grey with a twist to it yeah this one
was very low on dialogue I think the
first one I believe was more like here's
what your plot is gonna be it's saying
I'm Michael Ealy versus Morris Chestnut
he's the bad guy test that's the good
guy play for this woman's affection and
yeah I mean clearly it's like you meet a
guy that all is not what it appears to
be very Fifty Shades of Grey
except whereas Fifty Shades of Grey
keeps it in the bedroom this guy he just
can't control himself yeah I mean those
sex scenes look pretty hot though sex
scenes look pretty high you go yeah I'm
not gonna make sex look fun they make
sexist but if you once you try it you
will be hooked
trust me it's like BASE jumping really I
can't get it out of your head after you
do it just one really yeah turns out
I've written Diaries on the subject I've
been waiting till marriage not because
I'm a Christian it's because I just I'm
scared okay well I might wait until
marriage to see this movie or I might
never see it because it looks like it's
trying a little bit too hard to be that
kind of thriller my favorite shot that
trailer is where it's Michael Ealy until
you realize he's a crazy stalker and
it's him and then a full moon in the
background does he turn into a wick who
really really need that is he gonna
become Taylor Lautner I know exactly
what you mean I mean especially by them
trying a little too hard like I feel
like this film would work if they went
you know I can't fear you're like he
made a little comparison there right and
I could see why this is about obsession
and stalking and what I loved about Cape
Fear was how they went all out with like
the violence and everything like they
took it to another level
and I feel like this film is trying to
look really edgy and hard but something
tells me they're holding
okay here's my questions about this
movie those that Michael Ealy you look
at the guy he could have any girl he
wanted so why is he just gonna stay
obsessed with one chick when he can crew
it's like oh oh you don't like my
violent temper beating up a guy at a gas
station guess what there's six billion
other women on the planet there would
love for me to beat the crap out of
somebody
at a Texaco speaking of dark comedy
Morris Chestnut he's in the movie too
and you gotta wonder she's sleeping with
Morris Chestnut and she gets in bed with
Michael Ealy who is gonna be the better
lover brother he just they should just
do a DP situation that's what I say
but DP situation yeah I don't know that
you don't know what DP means no you
don't wanna deal now you're gonna find
out double penetration oh my oh oh dear
God yeah you're saying yourself for
marriage but you know what double
penetration is well there's a lot I know
but it makes me feel the shame I'm
getting a Michael Ealy vibe from you
you're gonna onion I'm just peeling
layers and I didn't want to say well you
know what you're saying though like
again it logically makes sense to not do
that to you to a girl and all that [ __ ]
what I think is if they explored some
type of psychology behind this guy that
would be really into some sort of wiring
that went wrong maybe he took a shot
playing football in high school you just
can't get it back maybe something
happened in Michael ILI's past then is
like oh now it's irreparable damage to
his psyche but I gotta tell you Morris
Chestnut every time I see that one
screen that is the perfect guy if I had
to switch teams and play for the other
side I am totally trying to take down
Morris Chestnut at the bar and he's like
dark chocolate you know oh yeah and
that's my favorite kind of cacao yeah
every kind of black idea anyway guys
thanks for tuning in to the channel if
you're new to it you can subscribe to
the real rejects you can obviously check
out mark on the schmoes know channel
where I I did one if he you know when I
came on that podcast I'm so [ __ ] there
oh we love having you on as you go
sooner like he mentioned we had you can
watch a lot of our guests get nervous
every Thursday killing them she is yes
it's crazy it's like my first legit
guess
your alleged guests really yeah buddy oh
yeah we should have you on somebody else
then bring up the term DP you gonna
you're gonna think about that I can't
get it out of my head
xvideos calm you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram Twitter you guess a
vine text videos we don't do by know you
can follow us on Instagram schmoes know
movies and on twitter at Mo's no suite
yes you can follow us on all our social
networks because if I get enough
followers I can get even more product
placement yeah yeah for things such as
popcorn bags popcorn bags are great you
know they hold your popcorn the old
other items too you know um you didn't
know what a DP is do you know the
[ __ ] parties I am aware what a
[ __ ] party is and the fact they bring
me up means I need to check something no
there's no hole the bottom of it we're
good to go
well I was gonna say a hole will be
there soon no no my goodness I'm
throwing you your first [ __ ] party oh
well it should be with someone you know
feel like you know each other we met
like three sides anyway popcorn bags